nos dicen escribe 7 centésimas como una
fracción y como un decimal tomen lápiz y
papel y traten de resolver esto por su
cuenta antes de que lo resolvamos juntos
primero vamos a escribirlo como fracción
cuál será el denominador de esta
fracción nos piden 7 centésimas y lo
digo así para darles una pista siete
centésimas creo que ya se dieron una
idea se trata de centésimas vamos a
escribirlo el denominador es centésimas
y cuántas centésimas tenemos pues
tenemos 7 vamos a usar un color
diferente para que quede claro son 7
centésimas y ya lo tenemos es esto
expresado como una fracción y cuál es su
expresión decimal pensemos en las
posiciones de los decimales esta es la
posición de las unidades escribimos un
espacio en blanco en este lugar a un
lado tenemos el punto decimal aquí está
la posición de las décimas y esta es la
posición de las centésimas
representar 7 centésimas para que todo
quede claro aquí están las unidades
aquí las décimas y acá las centésimas
que es divertido decirlo así centésimas
unidades décimas y centésimas
cuántas unidades tenemos ninguna unidad
cero unidades cuantas décimas tenemos no
hay décimas cuantas centésimas tenemos
tenemos siete centésimas ok ya no es tan
divertido pronunciarlo así 7 centésimas
así que lo escribimos así si queremos
escribirlo un poco más claro lo
escribimos así cero unidades cero
décimas siete centésimas resolvamos otro
ejemplo aquí nos dicen selecciona la
forma escrita de cada número del lado
izquierdo tenemos diferentes
representaciones tenemos números
escritos como decimales como fracciones
como otro decimal y queremos relacionar
cada número con su forma escrita
donde tenemos combinaciones de números y
palabras pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo al ver el primer número de
aquí nos damos cuenta de que no tiene
unidades y al movernos una posición a la
derecha del punto decimal tenemos la
posición de las décimas podemos ver que
hay cuatro de esas décimas aquí
este número es cuatro décimas que
corresponde a esta opción de acá lo
rellenamos o si resuelven esto en el
portal de khan academy sólo tienen que
hacer clic sobre él para rellenar lo que
hay con este aquí lo leemos como cuatro
de diez o cuatro décimas por lo que esto
corresponde a la misma opción cuatro
décimas lo rellenamos también ahora
veamos la última opción no hay unidades
no hay décimas pero si hay cuatro
centésimas lo volvía a decir así es
divertido
cuatro centésimas corresponde con esta
columna por lo que rellenamos esta
opción con esto terminamos